(sounds of helicopter propeller)
Good Morning, Facebook.
It's me, Gary
and that's DRock.
We're filming DailyVee 32, 31?
- [DRock] 31.
- 31.
I like being  31.
Dave Winfield, when I
was a kid, as a Yankee.
(helicopter motor sounds)
(slow trance music)
Typical day in a casino.
Conference room in
Connecticut.
You know, just doing my thng.
What I think is most interesting,
is the following,
which is what I've
spent my career on.
Sometimes I've done it well,
now I'm really doing it.
One on one on one CRM.
What I mean by that is in the
same way you think of customers
and knowing them,
let's use Rick in a positive way.
(audience laughter)
I got to make it up for you, Rick.
If Rick is doing great,
Rick may not be motivated
by another eight thousand
dollars or four percent
he just might not. He may
be motivated by an extra
couple of weeks. So I'll give
you an interesting,
we have an unlimited
vacation policy.
Let me explain.
Did that for first two years.
Then I created a
mandatory three weeks
because a lot of kids,
especially youngsters
they didn't know how
to handle it so
some of them didn't use it all
and then you had some
that used it a lot.
But here's what's funny
we still have it unlimited,
I'm thrilled to fire you for
your vacation actions even
though we have an unlimited,
yes, we have an unlimited policy.
That doesn't mean you should
be on vacation 94 days a year.
Got it?
Obviously, I do those 5, 10
minute meetings with people
when they first start. You've
seen that on DailyVee countlessly.
But these hour breakfasts with
six different people just
shooting the shit. Always trying
to move the needle in making
me more accessible and human
and real to even my own employees
as much as I stand and
spew it on this show.
Genuinely wanting a relationship
with them is the actual
answer to this question.
As much as I stand in front of
them in all hands on meetings
or send emails, it's still tough
to make somebody feel comfortable.
Even if they've been with
me two, three years at
the company to just reach out
and say hey and talk about
their wants, dreams and needs.
And so I'm continuously trying
to hack at creating scenarios,
you know a breakfast like this
allows something to come up
about a favorite TV show that I
then can mention in the elevator
that then leads to six months
from now that person when
they're struggling because one
other person is making their life
miserable for them to actually
come and speak to me about it
versus finding another job.
I'm the least fucking confused
person you will ever meet.
And I need you to understand that.
And the way I solve for that is
to stand in front of you,
stand in front of you at scale
and say I am here to have any
conversation you need at any time.
You know, I call it the
Ricky Henderson rule.
Ricky Henderson is a baseball
player in 1984 that winked at me
as he was going into the dugout.
And he became my favorite
baseball player and I supported
him and bought his stuff and
bought his baseball cards.
You know, it's very hard.
I have 600 and change
employees right now
finding time for everybody
is very, very difficult but
even the five minute meetings,
though are so short,
create context. It's amazing,
I've been sitting with a lot lately
as I'm catching up and you know
whether I know the town they
grew up in or their favorite
sports team or what
their ambition is that context
becomes meaningful.
And it's important. And I think
it has a huge impact on culture.
When you don't become
a faceless CEO or
head of this, head of that
and you become Gary or Emily
or Ricky it becomes totally
different and by saying
hello for five minutes in a
meeting it leads to them saying
hello to you in the elevator
which leads to them saying
hello at the holiday party
which leads to them coming
to you actually on an issue.
It's building an
actual relationship.
What matters the most, in my
opinion, and what I think is
absolutely the future of HR
is the one on one nature of it.
Some people want
work-life balance,
some want more money,
some want more challenges,
this is school and
school doesn't work.
You can't put everybody
in the same box.
They're driven by different
things and more importantly,
you know this and
all of you know this,
you're driven by different things
at different points in your life.
When you're 22 and
you didn't grow up
with anything you want money.
When you crushed it
and your 32 and you
found the man of your dreams
and you want to start a family
you not sure you want to be a
working dad maybe a stay at,
there's just a million,
by the way I tell my employees
I take it very rogue,
I tell my employees
I'm like I'm ready for tragedy.
We have three situations
right now where people
are dealing with tragedy.
Deaths, mental illness.
I'm mentally and my company
is prepared for that.
You need a four month
sabbatical, fine.
Real stuff. Just real stuff.
I love my non-billable overhead.
It's why we're the fastest
growing agency ever.
'Cause we actually have continuity.
'Cause we actually have a team.
'Cause we actually
have longevity.
I think this is entrepreneurial
enough from what I can sense
and I don't know and you
have different things it's a
big company but I think you
should challenge yourself
to come up with one or two
unique HR driven things
every year. Things that you
haven't done in the past.
But more than anything,
it doesn't matter what tactic,
it's not tactics, its religion.
If you actually give a crap
about every person here,
one by one, you will win.
You got it.
(slow trance music)
What's up Snapchat?
Sorry I have been MIA.
Just running a
fucking business.
(slow techno music)
Just headed back to O'Hare now.
Kind of intense day.
Three flights, DRock,
not a bad day.
Love when the hustle
comes through.
That was a lot of fun.
Leaving something in the car,
Literally, the only time
I had to take both my kids
to school on the same day--
- You didn't leave one
of the kids in the car?
- No. That would've
been amazing.
No, but the only time,
the singular,
I've taken a lot of them
individually by themselves.
I had to take two, my wife
had to have a quick procedure
we're in between nannies. Right?
- [Woman] That's always fun.
- So I went and did that and
my little guy is like 30 minutes
after my daughter and I get
out of the cab to take him to
the coffee shop that he likes
to hang out in 30 minutes
before school and left his
book bag in the taxi,
gone forever.
- [Woman] Ooh. Bad dad. (inaudible)
- I know. I texted my wife
this is such good material.
Oh, by the way,
I do a daily vlog.
That's what DRock is
doing If you are curious.
- I'm aware so--
- Got it. Okay, good.
You know what is good, DRock?
That's the first time I just
realized eventually enough
people will know about it that
I don't have to say it every time.
Cartier, an iconic brand,
always flattered when
big brands of non-clients
are asking me to come in
and bring value.
And so, that is what
I do for a living.
Because really I'm a salesman.
When I go and talk to all
these brands that love
to make commercials
and catalogs,
I don't care about awards.
I don't give a crap about
the south of France
and winning an award.
I care about selling crap.
Right? And this sells crap.
That went extremely well.
I really enjoy that great crew.
I am a retailer and
salesman at heart.
Those are always
extra special for me.
Sal, it's GaryVee.
You got to hit me up.
When are we
hanging out, my man?
(woman and man laughing)
- Hi! That's awesome.
Oh my God that is really
awesome. Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
- Thank you.
Now grinding back,
luckily DRock wasn't sitting
with me in the flight between
New York and Chicago 'cause
I actually slept which is a
rarity but really been on
for five hours sleep.
The last two weekends
I haven't been able to
catch up on sleep or rest so
feeling run down for me
which is a rarity because
we're 31 episodes in and
everybody just said what?
(DRock laughing)
Truth is by even saying it
I got competitive plus
I got rest there plus I got
energy so I'm about to
crush this flight from
Chicago to Dallas.
Just grinding, right?
Listen, I have no problem
with anybody jumping off this
series because I promise you
if you're smart you're going to
find the layers and the things
underneath but like if you're
only one chess move
this is going to be quite basic.
Working hard and grinding
and making stuff happen.
It's what it is. It's crazy you
think you might be getting
exhausted, oh sorry, got right
on the sound there DRock.
You feel that?
Didn't hear it? Nice.
Oh did I take there mic?
- [DRock] No you held it.
- I was handling it, nice.
Anyway, I like some
people were like
GaryVee, man, this is intense.
30 episodes.
Even people coming
at it as a zing.
Show some other stuff or
this, that and the other thing.
I'm like, 30 episodes, man,
this is been 30 years.
(DRock and Gary laughing)
I wish DailyVee started
in May 1998.
It would be a library of
complete and utter exhaustion.
- [DRock] That'd be cool.
- It would be cool, right?
- [DRock] Mhmmm.
- 30 episodes, three months,
this is forever.
This has been forever.
This is what so many successful
people's careers look like.
Not just mine. And even
successful parents,
successful everything.
Anything special takes a
combination of talent
and work ethic and
all these things.
Look, I have the audacity
to dream big things.
And they come at the expense of
taking a helicopter to
Connecticut and back. They come
at the expense of flying to
Chicago for an hour
and then leaving.
they come at the expense
of landing at 1:30 tonight
and having a
5:40 AM wake-up call.
Everything has a cost,
you just have to make sure
that the price you are paying
is what you want in return.
Ooh.
(DRock laughing)
You ready DRock?
Matt, Mattie McClude,
who is a great dude
just left a comment saying
"Also, lighten up on DRock
"you've been zinging him a lot."
So, DRock I just wanted to
set the record straight here.
I'm sorry. I love you so much.
And I zing the ones
I love the most.
Right, mom, dad, AJ?
(both laughing)
It's funny, when I read that
I was like oh man I must
really starting to love DRock.
I want to have that care
and level of relationship
with those individuals and
that's what I always hope.
Unfortunately, they don't
always go that way
but that is my aspiration.
Okay.
Thank you.
DRock, this is how
I like the airports.
Real fucking quiet.
Real quiet. For the hustlers.
When you run a company of this
size what happens is you can't
get to everything on that day.
There are things that I know
that are broken today,
that I am doing things to fix
but you won't feel it for
three or four months
'cause that's just the
way that it is. Right?
That's just the game.
I've been thinking about
what do I say up here that
for the 300, 400 of you that
I don't know well enough
that you hear and
you don't believe.
This is what I think
about every day.
That's 100% what I'm going
to do after this talk.
What was said today and how
many people didn't believe it
and how do I make sure
they do eventually, right?
That's what I do for a living.
There's been things that
have happened in the last
18, 24 months around a lot
of different categories that
made me feel that way.
I would argue, I would argue
this is maybe now as
of this announcement,
the next most important role
in this company underneath me.
And so it is a big one.
As of today, starting on Monday,
we now have a Chief Heart Officer.
And that Chief Heart Officer
is actually here.
So I think we should grab
our Chief Heart Officer.
(audience cheering)
To create a position
that really is me, right?
The scalable version of what
I do with you guys one on one
in those meetings to have the
autonomy to make decisions
that make no sense
on paper but make a
whole lot of sense on heart.
We want to build the single
greatest human organization
in the history of time.
(slow trance music)